el mismo año que la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos derogó la sentencia
América Latina vivió un avance en
materia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos con la despenalización del
aborto por ejemplo en Colombia y en
algunos estados mexicanos cómo puede
influir este retroceso en Estados Unidos
y en los países de América Latina que
están avanzando o quieren avanzar a la
hacia la despenalización bueno
ha incluido De hecho hay un retroceso en
los en los derechos de las mujeres y
entonces la situación en América Latina
como que es muy variada es muy
contrastante
coincidimos en algunos puntos pero pero
en otros nos distanciamos Por decirlo de
alguna manera lo acabas de mencionar lo
que está pasando en Colombia pero por
ejemplo también en Colombia la corte
constitucional aseguró en mayo pasado
que en ese país realmente no existe el
derecho de las mujeres a decidir si
interrumpen o no su embarazo también
está la situación Por ejemplo en en Perú
una niña de 13 años que ha sido
recientemente
acusada y sentenciada por abortar luego
de cuatro años de abusos por parte de su
padrastro y al mismo tiempo por ejemplo
acá en México la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación reiteró que las
mujeres mexicanas pueden incluso
desconocer las leyes estatales porque
hay por supuesto una ley general y leyes
estatales al respecto en los estados del
norte muy cercanos a Texas donde también
hay un conservadurismo muy evidente pues
la suprema corte en la de justicia en la
nacional acaba de decir que pueden
desconocer estas estas restricciones al
el derecho a la interrupción legal del
embarazo y acceder a ello y que es
obligación en en el en el territorio
mexicano de la secretaría de salud
brindar estos servicios de manera libre
gratuita y segura
ahora los grupos anti derechos
conservadores y religiosos como vimos en
Estados Unidos tienen una gran fuerza
popular Incluso en países donde el
aborto Es legal Por qué cuesta tanto
lograr una despenalización social del
aborto Cuáles son los riesgos de esto
Mira este las feministas pensamos que
poniendo todo en blanco y negro es decir
en leyes tendríamos ya un avance más
asegurado en los derechos de las mujeres
pero resulta y ahora con el análisis que
estamos haciendo es que
las leyes tienen que ir acompañadas
también de un de de no solamente de la
voluntad política sino de la voluntad
social y la voluntad cultural Ahí es
donde vamos muy atrás y por eso hay tal
desfasamiento rápido te lo platico la
encuesta mundial de valores
wss por sus siglas en inglés
esta se dedican a hacer encuestas sobre
distintos tópicos entre ellos El Avance
del de la del de la equidad de género y
coinciden en que hay una crisis mundial
del desarrollo humano el índice de
desarrollo humano mundial descendió en
el veinte por primera vez Desde que la
WS está haciendo estos registros
Entonces vamos políticamente y le
Aparentemente legalmente hacia adelante
pero en lo cultural en lo social no
vamos al mismo ritmo por eso se están
presentando estas disparidades